[Music]
hey guys I'm chastity here with your
guide to the top co-op games to play
this holiday delivered by Pizza Hut the
holiday season is all about getting
together and sharing gather your friends
family and even your most annoying
sibling and share the gift of fun with
these great couch co-op games and while
you're gaming together share some treats
the Pizza Hut triple treat box to be
exact the triple treat box is a limited
time holiday offer which includes two
medium one topping pizzas breadsticks
and the ultimate Hershey's chocolate
chip cookie all packed into three medium
pizza boxes and wrapped in an exciting
holiday themed box now that you've got
your snacks planned out what should you
play well first up we have rocket League
it's soccer with cars it's ridiculous
it's fun it's a futuristic sports action
game where you use booster rig vehicles
to crash into balls to score goals many
heated rocket League matches have
happened right here in the GameSpot
office and we still can't get enough of
it you can play with up to four players
locally get the collector's edition for
ps4 or Xbox one for $29.99 next up we
have lego star wars the force awakens
you don't have to be a kid to love this
game but it would help if you liked Star
Wars - players can relive the movie as
all the heroic characters from the force
awakens
rey finn han solo chewy even that cutie
bb-8 get it for ps4 or Xbox one for
$59.99 or on the Wii U for 39.99 if you
want to have fun with food try
overcooked overcooked is a chaotic co-op
cooking game for up to four players as a
team of chefs you must prep cook and
serve different dishes before your
customers storm off this game gets
intense and if you're not organized
there might be yelling but man is it fun
get the new over cooked gourmet edition
for ps4 or Xbox one for $19.99 if you
want to play games with a big group get
the jack box party pack three the newest
jack box party pack comes with five
games to test your brand and mess with
your friends from the makers of you
don't know jack jack box party pack
three comes with fun and frantic games
like trivia murder party a deadly quiz
show and
making it a sneaky game for tricksters
the best part is you don't need extra
controllers up to eight players can join
in on the fun using their phones tablets
or computers you can get party pack
three for Xbox one or ps4 for $24.99
if platformers are more your style try
Rayman legends
up to four players can play as Rayman
and Friends sharing the same screen as
your group progresses there is a wide
range of levels including special
musical levels which are incredibly fun
it's a gorgeous cartoonish good time and
still one of the best platformers on
current gen consoles get it for Xbox one
Wii U or ps4 for as low as $19.99 if you
want to combine cartoonish fun with a
shooter try plants vs. zombies garden
warfare 2 both the shooter and a tower
defense game the sequel to garden
warfare offers new classes and modes
with familiar gameplay this time around
the zombies have conquered and the
plants are on the attack you can play
with or against a friend in split-screen
across every mode get it for Xbox one or
ps4 for $39.99 for an even more chaotic
shooter check out enter the gungeon
enter the gungeon is an intense
shoot-'em-up dungeon crawler this game
is full tilt madness in co-op mode where
you shoot loot dodge roll and table flip
your way through the gungeon it can be a
bit frustrating but often with amusing
results download it on ps4 for $14.99
for kids of all ages there's minecraft
ps4 edition minecraft is pretty
recognizable now on the ps4 edition you
can play in co-op in two player and four
players split-screen modes this console
edition features two fun minigames tumbl
is a competitive mode where players
destroy the floor beneath each other's
feet battle is a fight for survival with
a choice of three maps get minecraft for
ps4 for $19.99 for the aspiring
musicians in your group jam out with
rock band for the latest version of rock
band offers the same familiar gameplay
of becoming a full band with a singer
guitarist bassist and drummer what's new
is the revamped world tour campaign mode
and freestyle solos there are thousands
of legacy tracks you can download which
is good because the built-in setlist
isn't the strongest get ready to rock
out on ps4 and Xbox one a full band at a
box bundle will set you back 160 $9.99
and finally for you Movers & Shakers we
recommend just Stan's 2017 Just Dance
2017 allows up to six players to use
smartphones to play with a just dance
controller app get ready to bust and
move to new tracks like Justin Bieber's
sorry and see us keep thrills it's also
a lot of fun to see your friends sloppy
attempts at copying the dance moves as
best as they can you can get just dance
2017 for wii u ps4 and Xbox one for
$49.99 those are your top co-op games
this holiday season delivered by Pizza
Hut once you pick a game to share don't
forget to share some food with the Pizza
Hut triple treat box every specially
marked triple treat box includes $10 off
an Xbox game and a chance to win an Xbox
one s and a custom red Pizza Hut
controller Pizza Hut is giving them away
every hour until December 24th you can
find a code on the inside front flap of
a specially marked triple treat box and
enter it at Pizza Hut xbox one Escom for
a chance to instantly win an Xbox one s
happy gaming and happy eating
I'm chastity and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you